yes
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you let me know
awesome
all right my mic yes
excellent welcome everybody um
i'm alexander rose i'm the executive
director here at long now and uh
a while back when uh when i saw this
book come out i realized that there's so
many times where we have talks with from
astronomers about billions of years or
geologists about millions of years but
you know there's this one passage that
when stuart brand launched long now he
wrote
uh in the kind of launching essay which
was civilization is revving itself into
a pathological
pathologically short attention span the
trend might be coming from the
acceleration of technology the short
horizon perspective of market-driven
economics the next election perspective
of democracies or the distractions
personal multitasking
all are on the increase some sort of
balancing corrective to the
short-sightedness is needed and that was
what launched long now and we have we've
kind of dealt with a lot of those
subjects but it's very rare that we deal
with that personal multitasking part and
so when i saw this book that was a
perfect opportunity to kind of look not
at necessarily the next 10 000 years but
at least the arc of our lives
and how we think about that in a more
personal way and dory clark is first
perfect person to tell us about that
thank you
so we've all been through a lot
over the last couple of years
i know even here in san francisco it's a
it's a new thing to be able to come back
out to events and to be around other
people and to be able to socialize
freely we all had
things
in march april may of 2020 that we
thought we were going to do
and
almost none of them happened
we got hit by a tidal wave
and i remember for me you probably all
have your moment when you first realized
what kovid was going to
be
when there were the first intimations of
what would happen and
coming at it two and a half years later
in a talk like this where we're able to
reconvene and reconnect is kind of
amazing because
i took a selfie of myself i wanted to
remember this in march of
2020 i was in new york city where i was
living at the time i was giving a talk
at hunter college
and about 150 people had rsvp'd for this
talk
and by the time the talk rolled around
about 20 intrepid souls showed up
because they were starting to realize
that something was amiss something was
awry and maybe it wasn't a good idea
anymore to be coming out to an event
so
we had to recalibrate
we had to suddenly discover terminology
that we had never used before social
distancing we suddenly had to
stand in line at the grocery store we
suddenly had to
find new ways of relating to each other
we
fled from downtown
and certainly that was the case in san
francisco as well as new york and
started
living our lives in so many ways online
and we had to do it fast
there had been you know for 15 20 years
scholars of
the study of work from home and remote
work and how could it how could it
possibly function and what would it look
like and what would it take for
companies to be able to accede to this
future that everybody thought was
inevitable but would happen over the
course of decades and it turns out of
course that somehow we figured it out
because we had to
in the course of two or three weeks we
were all thrown into it and we
discovered pretty rapidly that there was
a downside to that that we would have to
cope with
but we did we figured it out
and in the meantime
the pandemic forced us to be innovative
in some positive ways
this is a picture with my mom that i
took also in march of 2020 my last
teaching gig that i did before
everything shut down was at duke
university i teach for their fuqua
school of business and i flew down from
new york to durham to teach my program
and when i landed when the plane landed
i checked my messages and there was a
notice that the school had shut down
but because i was doing an executive ed
program and everybody had already flown
in from around the world for the program
we decided to run it anyway
so the entire campus was shut and we
were the only people on campus for that
week doing the course but my mother
she was prescient the cdc was saying no
you don't need masks but my mother
taught herself how to sew masks by
watching videos in japanese and chinese
on youtube
that was a pretty innovative move
she wasn't the only one who was
innovating
i spent the summer of 2020 walking
around the streets of new york city
trying to make sense of this trying to
figure out what was going on and seeing
how people were making do in these
straightened circumstances
this was
an indian restaurant that i used to go
to in the east village of new york it
started out as a regular indian
restaurant you could dine in enjoy food
of course for a lot of 2020 it was
prohibited to eat indoors in new york
like here in san francisco so of course
they did you know take out and delivery
like a lot of places but they also did
something pretty creative they said what
resources do we have
that are not being tapped
what else could we offer to our
customers and they realized oh well we
could cook the food but we also have all
this food we have all these ingredients
and so they opened up
a grocery store within the restaurant
you can see they've got flour they've
got ketchup they've got all the
ingredients
they decided
to find a new way of looking at the
problem
this is a place in the washington
heights neighborhood
of new york city you may have seen uh on
film the musical version of the
neighborhood last summer with uh with
the movie in the heights that lin manuel
miranda did but in the actual washington
heights there's a little cafe a little
coffee shop called tazo and they have a
pretty unusual assortment of services
that they provide you can see on their
sign here they are a pastry shop they're
a cafe they're a wine bar oh and they're
an antique shop
they're an antique shop because when
the restrictions were created that you
could not dine indoors they said well we
have all this space what can we do with
this space and they realized they needed
a creative use for it the owner happened
to be an antique collector he said well
restaurants are closed but antique shops
are not
he moved his entire collection inside
and started selling it to his customers
the pandemic forced us to adapt
even
the poor
unloved for so long
qr code
finally got its day in the sun
i feel happy for the qr code
the truth of all of this
is we saw over the past two years
what short-term thinking can do
i'm not here to knock short-term
thinking in fact
it did all of us a lot of good
because the truth is in a crisis
in a moment
when all your expectations go out the
window
in a moment where it's uncertain you
don't know what's going to happen
things can change from day to day in
dangerous ways
we need the ability to pivot to adapt to
be agile short-term thinking
is great
but here's something that i believe and
i think you do too
short-term thinking has its place
and it can't be the only way that we
operate
as
humans
we tend to fall into ruts
we tend to keep doing what is working
for us
and over the past two years
all of us have over indexed on
short-term thinking we had to
there was not a choice you could make
two-year plans and then god would laugh
but now
finally
as we are
fingers crossed
entering a new moment when we're just a
little bit farther along
with covid with adapting to things with
being able to get the ground underneath
our feet a little bit more stable
i know that's a bad metaphor in
california but you know what i mean
i think it's time for us to recalibrate
short-term thinking
is great as far as it goes
but we also know that it's important
to start consciously retraining our
sites
but it's not something that happens on
its own it's not something that happens
naturally we have to consciously make a
change we have to consciously make a
shift
in terms of how we are viewing the world
and the steps that we're taking and i
know by dint of your being here by dint
of your being part of the long now
foundation that this is something that
you care about
so let's talk about what that actually
might look like
i wrote a book that came out last fall
called the long game how to be a
long-term thinker in a short-term world
and for me
one of the questions i really wanted to
explore was how can we actually apply
the principles of long-term thinking the
principles of strategic thinking to our
own lives to our own careers
many of us do this for our businesses
for those of you who you know are
entrepreneurs or you work inside
organizations this is this is something
that we consciously try to do you know
where are we going in five years in 10
years and 20 years
we often fail though to
really apply
that same lens to our own lives
and again i know
because you support the long now
foundation you are used to very
long-term thinking and that is
incredibly important
but it's also important to think about
how we can be living it out in our own
lives how can we manifest some of that
thinking
and it's an interesting question because
the truth is
right there's
pretty much no disagreement about this
almost everybody thinks
long-term thinking strategic thinking is
a good
thing
i was asked to give a talk a couple
years ago
by
the peter drucker forum it is
an organization based out of austria
that celebrates the great management
thinker peter drucker and they asked me
to give a talk about strategy
and i said well what facet what do you
want me to talk about they said you know
you know anything something about
strategy
i said okay
so i started
thinking
what is most interesting about strategy
what hasn't been talked about what what
angle could i find and what i realized
after pondering it for a bit is that for
me
the central question about strategy
about strategic thinking long-term
thinking
is if everyone seems to think it's a
good idea
why aren't we doing more of it
there was a study that was done a few
years ago by an organization called the
management research group they surveyed
10
000 senior leaders and of the 10
000
97 percent said that the single most
important thing they could do for the
future of their organization for their
organization success was to be better
long-term thinkers
97
literally almost everyone thinks this is
a good idea
and yet
a separate study that was done around
the same time
96
of the leaders surveyed said they didn't
have time
for strategic thinking
there is a huge disconnect going on in
our own lives
why is it that we are not
doing what we say
we believe in that we say is so
important
i mean
the truth is we know some of the reasons
we know the obvious reasons we have too
many meetings we have too much email
that's all true
there's distractions
but
what is often happening
for us
is that
we
are failing to make the conscious choice
to redirect our energy we're getting
sucked into the minutiae
and it creates
long-term consequences that can be
incredibly deleterious i mean just as
in a scale environmental sense us
going along and not really thinking
about things like climate
can create
massive consequences downstream
the same thing's true in our own lives
i have a friend who lives here in
california he's
nearby in sausalito named jonathan brill
and i
talked to him for my book the long game
and he said something had stayed with me
he said
the worst thing you can do
is to get a
highly competent group of people
together smart talented capable people
and tell them to win
at the wrong thing
because the problem is they will do it
now for all of us
we
don't want
to get to the end of the line
and realize that we have been optimizing
for the wrong thing
but if we keep getting sucked into the
short term if we let ourselves be sucked
into the short term of heads down do the
thing do the thing get to the next
meeting accomplish the next milestone
and we never actually lift our heads up
long enough to ask whether we're doing
the right things whether the things
we're doing should be done at all
whether our energies and our talents
might be better spent in other ways
if we don't ask those questions then we
risk
at the end of the line winning at the
wrong things
i want to prevent that from happening
for myself
and for you for all of us
so
what does it look like
well i know one of the things that's
most special
about the long now foundation is that
this is this is a bulwark this is an
organization that
has for so long put a stake in the
ground and said no this this matters we
have to zoom out we have to look at a
longer time frame than almost anybody is
used to a time frame that is far beyond
our own lifetimes
in order to make smarter choices and
better decisions
but i know also
it can be challenging sometimes when we
look at these timelines that are
too big for the human mind to even
really comprehend
to think about how it plays out in our
day-to-day how do we apply it how do we
live it what does it look like
and
what it reminded me of
is a quote from
rabbi tarfan
this is somebody
who lived
2 000 years ago
just after the destruction of the second
temple in 79 a.d
and
he said something that i think is
relevant for all of us
which is
you're not required
to complete the work
of perfecting the world
but neither are you permitted
to desist
from trying
we can't do it all we have to recognize
that we have to make peace with it
we're not going to get it all done
but there are things that we can do
there are things in fact
that we have to do that we are called
upon to do
i recently
bought a place in miami
and
and as you might imagine it's become a
popular
destination for my friends
i've had a lot of house guests the past
three to four months
and you can tell pretty fast who's a
good house guest
and who is not
we all
need to be better house guests
on earth
so how
how does it work
i've been thinking about this question a
lot and i imagine you have as well
and so i wanted to share with you seven
strategies that i hope might be helpful
that
have informed my thinking
and
might be useful to you
so the first thing that i realized going
back to this question of if strategy is
so great why don't we do it
one of the things that i realized is
that
for so many of us what is lacking what
is profoundly lacking
in our lives
is white space
in a very literal sense for most of us
if you
look at your
calendar
you're probably going to see a sea of
blue
literally white space
time that is unspoken for
is probably pretty scarce
and
it's not the worst thing in the world
but it has its
consequences a few years ago
when i was writing a previous book of
mine i interviewed david allen who some
of you may have heard of he's a
well-known productivity guru he wrote
the book getting things done
and
he told me something interesting
he said it doesn't take a huge amount of
time to have brilliant ideas
but what it takes
is space
it's almost like a zen coan if you roll
it around in your head
but it's true right i mean we all know
if you have to come up with some
innovation some new idea it's not oh i
need to set aside 40 hours and bang my
head against the desk that is not how
the brilliant ideas come
right
it comes
sometimes in a moment in a flash you're
in the shower you're walking you're
jogging you're doing something
but what enables it to come
is having the space to make the
connections
we will never get that space
if we are constantly pulled down
by details by worries by ruminations and
by back to back meetings that are so
intense we feel we can never catch up
we need white space if we are going to
have the mental bandwidth to be able to
even begin to engage in long-term
thinking
to be able to step back enough from our
present circumstances to entertain those
questions
so what i've realized in terms of how to
get it
we have to be vigilant we should be
really vigilant because the truth is
unfortunately it is literally in
everyone else's best interest
for you to be at their beck and call
it is way more convenient for other
people for you to respond within five
minutes to their
emails but it's not convenient for you
or for your ability to do long-term
thinking we have to be guarding the
perimeters and so i've come up with four
questions that i like to apply
sometimes we need a checklist frankly
whether you're an airline pilot whether
you're a surgeon
and also if you're a regular
professional dealing with the onslaught
of requests that come in modern life
the four questions that i like to ask
when a request comes through number one
what is
the actual cost involved
sometimes we delude ourselves sometimes
people say oh you know do you mind if i
just pick your brain for a few minutes
or whatever it is and you realize oh
all of a sudden the thing you see well
it's just a few minutes and suddenly the
call becomes a coffee suddenly you're
driving suddenly there's traffic and two
hours later
time has slipped away on something you
didn't quite want to do what is the
total cost
involved number two what's the physical
and emotional cost of the request i
think kovid has probably put this into
sharper relief for most of us
there are times frankly when we
are run down
times when we're burned out times that
are busy periods
and frankly things need to clear a
higher bar
in order to be worthwhile to say yes
we have to think about those things what
put this into relief for me
this is pre-coveted i had a friend that
invited me to speak at a conference in
the caribbean
sounded so cool ah i get a free trip to
the caribbean my friend's gonna be there
it sounded good i wanted to say yes
but there was something there was a
small voice inside me that said wait
wait don't say yes
yet and i looked at my calendar and i
realized i was traveling
all the week before
i was traveling all the week after
and i thought
would i actually enjoy this
if i had three consecutive weeks of
travel could i actually even have fun in
the caribbean or would i be so exhausted
from that
that it wouldn't be worth it
and i took the step back and i made the
quite hard decision
to say no
and i turned
down
number three
a question that i like to ask
is what's the opportunity cost we so
often when we are considering a request
say well should i do this or should i
not do this that is actually the wrong
question
the right question is should i do this
or should i do literally anything else
in the universe that takes that amount
of time
our lives are one
unit
we have to start thinking of them that
way
and fourth and finally time is always
helpful here as long now fans no
how will you feel about this a year from
now will you feel bad that you said no
will you feel bad you didn't go do it
or will it be forgotten
distance can be helpful but we have to
fight for that white space as a
prerequisite
for the work that we want to do to clear
the decks
number two
one of the principles
is actually my favorite in
writing the long game that i came across
was something that i first learned about
it but
that i first learned about nearly a
decade ago
i became familiar with the work of
francis frye who's a harvard business
school professor and her partner and
co-author anne morris
they wrote a book
back in 2012 called uncommon service it
was a book about the service industry
you know service industry businesses
everything from banks to airlines to
restaurants
and they were trying to look into the
question which probably most of us as
consumers have asked ourselves which is
why is it that so many businesses are
just average
why are so many businesses just mad
if you think about like oh what's a
great business most of us actually have
trouble coming up with it and yet of
course nobody's setting out to be
average they all want to be great they
just aren't why
and what they discovered was this
the businesses that were just meh
they
were all perfectly happy to try to say
oh we want to be great at this we want
to be great at that
they were all keen to do that everybody
loves to think about what they want to
be great at
but they refused to do something
that hindered them
and what they refused to do is they
refused to choose what to be bad at
what francis fry and anne morris
discovered is it
there's a lot of wishful thinking in our
lives and this is true if you run a
business frankly it's true for ourselves
as well we like to dream
that we can be excellent at something
and then just fine totally cool at
everything else
that's not how it works
i'll give you an example there was a
bank that they profiled that was
actually a very successful bank
and this bank they did something
interesting unlike almost every other
bank these guys stayed open really late
they were open until eight o'clock
weeknights they were open on weekends
fantastic their customers loved it
obviously
but why doesn't every bank do it you
probably know the answer which is that
it's expensive
but what this bank did
they found a way to pay for it
the way they paid for it is
they took the savings rate they're the
rate on savings deposits they shrunk it
down they made it almost non-existent it
was kind of terrible
but to their customers it didn't really
matter
it was a lot more important it was a lot
more salient to be able to go to the
bank at 7 30 at night
but most companies are not willing to
make those hard choices and most people
are not either
if we are ever to truly excel at
something if we're willing to
take what's necessary to be great we
have to be willing to choose what to be
bad at what are we willing to give up
to get there
most of us refuse to choose
and by not choosing
we stay average
that's when i learned that long-term
thinking is in a lot of ways a test of
character
it's a test of the courage
to make choices
number three
we also have to balance our portfolio
one of the things that i learned that
was a little uncanny to me but of course
if you think about it long enough it
makes sense
as i was writing the long game which is
a book about strategic thinking
long-term thinking
as i was writing it i began to realize
in so many ways it felt like an
investment book
i felt like i was writing a personal
finance book
of course it's not about money or
personal finance at all
but the principles
about the compound value
of one's time one's energy one's efforts
are actually remarkably similar
and it's also true
that we need to think about balancing
our portfolios
for most of us if you literally know one
thing about personal finance what you
probably know is that it is a bad idea
to put all your eggs in one basket right
you don't want to own one stock
most people think that's a pretty bad
idea you want to balance your portfolio
you want to have some of your money in
cash and some of your money in moon
shots
right and
it's true in investing
it's also true
in our lives
so
this is
san francisco silicon valley you guys
i'm sure are familiar with
google now alphabets uh famous 20
time
now
the premise behind this is that uh
google i'll call them that for the sake
of argument uh
has historically encouraged its
employees to spend up to 20 of their
time on more speculative activities
now let's put the asterisk in i know
many googlers they say that's not really
a thing anymore
but
it should be
and it actually
is uncommon
but it's not obsolete
studies estimate that about 10 percent
of googlers
still take advantage of 20
time this is how google news was
invented this is how gmail was invented
it is the opportunity
to explore
without the immediate need for a payoff
it is the opportunity to explore
in ways that you
suspect
but are not certain
may pay off in a big way in the future
this is something that is incredibly
valuable
certainly for google
if
you're creating the next gmail
but i want to argue it's incredibly
valuable for us as well
we should be creating 20 time in our own
lives
so often
we tend to just
focus in we have our day job okay we're
doing our day job the rest of our time
might be taken up with family or other
responsibilities
i want to urge you to think about
carving out time maybe twenty percent is
too much fine
you can find five percent but to think
about what your speculative long-term
activity is what is your learning edge
where are you
growing i'll give you an example of a
fairly random thing that i have been
doing for the past six years which this
is me as you can probably see i decided
in 2016
that i wanted to learn how to write
musical theater
and i had never done it before i had no
background i had really no idea
but i set myself to it and in the past
six years i have been accepted to and
have completed
one of the nation's top musical theater
training programs i've written a
complete musical i've done multiple
musical theater fellowships
you've probably heard the saying and i
think you've probably experienced it in
your own life i know i have that we tend
to overestimate what we can accomplish
in a day
and we tend to underestimate what we can
accomplish in a year
i want to suggest that is even more true
when we get to two years five years ten
years
you can go
from a zero start to actually becoming
quite accomplished at something if you
give yourself enough time we fail to
recognize just just as we sometimes miss
the value of investing
dollars a month in your twenties
we tend to miss
exactly
how much we can learn and how much we
can grow and how skilled we can become
if we invest time starting now over a
period of years
so
maybe ask yourself what is your 20 time
what could that be
now
something that comes up a lot
when it comes to
long-term thinking and
pursuing long-term projects
is
this question of
when and whether to quit
because the thing about a long-term
project is that oftentimes it takes a
long time
and
it can almost feel like you're going
into a dark tunnel
right
because you don't really know
what's going on you don't really know
for sure
if it's working
there's an economist at the university
of chicago named david galenson
and he's done a lot of study around the
art world
and
there are some people
like picasso
that from the time he was
young he was in his early 20s everybody
said he was a genius his whole life
everybody thought he was a genius that
is very handy
if people say that about you
but the truth is for most of us
we are not anointed in our 20s and
celebrated for the duration of our
entire lives
it doesn't really work that way
for a lot of us our lives are a lot more
like cezanne
cezanne
was not recognized at all
until he was in his mid to late 40s
up until that point
nobody thought he was any good
and the hard part
is
he wondered
if he was any good
you keep going because you think maybe
you think you think you've got something
but maybe they're right and you're not
it can be hard to tell in the moment
if something is not working
or if something is not working yet
that's the question right
so
some of you
if i didn't of being here
in the world of technology you may have
read or may be familiar with
the collaborations that stephen cutler
and peter diamandis have done they've
written some great books uh bold
abundance
they have explored the world of
so-called exponential technology the
kind of technology that grows at an
exponential pace
whether that's artificial intelligence
or self-driving cars or 3d printing if
we want to go back to something that we
now think of as normal
a good example is digital photography
that's also an exponential technology
they created a map a kind of framework
about
the progression of exponential
technology and what they
discovered
they came up with a name that i thought
was so captivating
it was
a concept that i thought had a lot of
relevance and a lot of salience for our
own lives they said that in the midst of
developing an exponential technology
there is something that they dubbed the
deception phase
now what is that
well it turns out that in the early days
of a technology and you've probably seen
this in the early days of a technology
everybody thinks it's so cool oh there's
so much buzz there's so much buzz
but you look at it and after a while it
just seems like huh well nothing's
really happening
it's not really going anywhere i've been
hearing about this for 20 years when's
this actually going to pan out
so overblown
you hear that a lot
the truth is
if you're somebody who's close to the
process you know it
if you're
moving forward with digital photography
and you're able to get it from point
zero one pixels to point zero two pixels
to point zero four pixels
that's actually kind of amazing right
point zero eight
moving on and on it's actually kind of
amazing progression it's doubling it's
doubling and stubbling but the problem
is that
it's still
invisible to the naked eye
the world around you unless they are
looking very closely they can't tell the
difference it still looks like a big fat
zero
and so they dismiss it
they say well that's dumb
and you know
are you hope
you think you know
that you're making progress
but it's often very very hard to drown
out the voices of all the people around
you saying
it's so overblown
that's the deception phase
because once
we cross
as they say the whole number barrier
once we make enough progress to get from
1 to 2 to 4 to 16
all of a sudden people start to say whoa
where did that come from
it's been doubling all along
they just couldn't see it but for so
many of us
if we're working on a project that's
important to us
if we are
building a career
things take time
it can be very hard to keep going
but we have to keep going
if we see that progress
we have to keep moving forward because
that is the only way to get to the other
side is to get through that deception
phase
i promised you seven
let's go
number five
strategic patience
i personally
have never been a fan of patience
certainly not regular patients when i
was a little kid my mom used to say i
was so impatient
because
frankly i kind of hated being a little
kid i was so offended i couldn't drive i
was so offended i couldn't vote i was
offended i couldn't start a business
there was so much i wanted to do and i
couldn't
and she'd say well just be patient
and
the way i heard that
i think frankly the way she meant it was
kind of
just shut up for a little while
just stop
that's not the kind of patience that i
like i don't think i'm ever going to
make peace with that
but
i created a new term
and it's one that i like better which is
strategic patience
because for me what we have to do is
simultaneously recognize two things
number one
sometimes things do take a while
and that can be exceptionally annoying
i don't like it that they take a while
sometimes but you know what being mad at
the seed does not make the seed grow
faster it takes however long it takes
we recognize that but it's also true
that we don't have to be passive in the
face of it we don't have to just sit
back and wait and hope
we can come up with hypotheses
we can be doing things we can be testing
things we can be trying things
that will help that will hasten what
we're doing we have to be thoughtful
about recognizing what it takes to get
there that it may take longer than we
want but that we're willing to make that
bet we're willing to make that
investment there was an interview a
decade ago in wired magazine
jeff bezos
was interviewed
and they asked him what is it
that is amazon's competitive advantage
why is amazon so successful
and what he said i think is quite
powerful he said amazon is willing to
invest on a seven year time frame
if it takes seven years for something to
show a profit
it's okay
he said our competitors are only willing
to invest on a three-year time frame
they have to turn a profit within that
time frame if they don't they're going
to scrap it they're not even going to
try it that is the competitive advantage
i think there's something powerful in
that i mean you can imagine this is true
right in most corporations whatever
executive is spearheading the initiative
he or she might be gone in three years
why would they bother
why would they bother to invest in an
initiative that someone else is going to
get the glory for
the incentives are not lined up right
but
if we
like amazon are willing to make
choices
to defer the gratification
because the good news
we're still going to be us
in seven years the benefits will accrue
to us
in our lives in our careers and the
impact that we want to make if we can be
willing
to out weight and outlast
the people around us
if we can be
willing to endure the deception phase
for longer it enables us to tackle
bigger
harder more meaningful more strategic
problems
it's how amazon was able to build a
competitive moat with things like amazon
web services or amazon prime
and frankly it's how we can build a
competitive moat in our own lives
by doing work
that is more meaningful and more
powerful than other people are willing
to attempt who are seeking a quick
payoff for it
number six
so silicon valley is actually pretty
good about this
fail fast
we know that failure
in many places around the world is
stigmatized pretty heavily you get one
chance you blow it all right sorry no
more chances
here
you get other chances which i think is
quite powerful
it's also important to recognize
that something is not a failure
until you call it
it's not a failure until you stop trying
and i'll give you one example from my
own career since we're talking about
how this applies at work
i wanted to be
in academia
i i was one of the you know kind of
geeky people that loved school
i loved uh my professors i admired them
so much
and so after i finished college i got a
master's degree after i finished my
master's degree i said well i want to do
this i want to be a professor and so i
applied to three different doctoral
programs
and i got turned down by all of them
i didn't even have a plan b
i
assumed i would get into one i had good
grades it was shocking to me that i did
not get into any of them i didn't know
what to do
i
came up with a plan b pretty fast i got
a job as a journalist and i thought okay
well there's writing you know there's
there's you know asking questions and
being intellectually curious you know so
i i moved the ball forward
but of course a year later i got laid
off from my job as a journalist and sort
of had to had to keep going and keep
reinventing myself
but today
i actually
have managed to find a way in the side
door i teach for two different top 10
business schools for duke and columbia i
don't have a phd i don't have an mba i
went to liberal arts schools i didn't
even take any college business classes
i was able to climb in the side window
of academia
by
networking and connecting and getting
experience
and not
giving up
on my vision of being able to be part of
the academy
and teaching and learning and things
that were important
it felt at the time when i was 22 like
the door was being shut forever
but it's actually pretty rare that the
door is shut forever and if we keep
looking for the windows that are open we
can often find it
i promised you seven
the last point
that i wanted to make and soon
we're going to be having a a
conversation uh sander is going to be
leading a chat and i know many of you
have been submitting questions and i'm
excited to tackle them
the last point that i wanted to make is
that as we think
about our own long-term
future our own long-term vision
in a lot of ways the
north star that we can look to
is a really simple question
what kind of person
do you want to be
this is
a friend of mine her name is alyssa cohn
i write about her in the long game
and the reason i like her story
alyssa maybe like some of you guys was a
huge hamilton fan
she was really into it and when she
learned that lin-manuel miranda had a
new side project she was all in on it
she learned about freestyle love supreme
it was a show on broadway it's a
freestyle hip hop improv rap show and
even better
they created
an academy it was a training program to
teach regular people how to do freestyle
hip hop
just like the performers
she immediately said i'm in that sounds
great and she envisioned a cool fun
class where lots of other hamilton fans
like her were learning to rap
she shows up for class
and when she shows up she realizes it's
alyssa
and about 20
guys who are all wearing hoodies who are
all about two decades younger than her
and who are all extremely good rappers
this was not very comfortable
after the first class
completely jasoned completely mortified
by her inability to
immediately break out into rap
she emailed the instructor and she said
i'm really sorry to do this i feel like
i should withdraw i i it's just you know
i don't fit in i don't i don't think i
can do this and he wrote back to her
with some incredibly wise words
he said alyssa
the goal
is not to turn you into a professional
rapper
the goal
is to help you become a more creative
and uninhibited person
and she thought about it and she
realized
oh right
that is my goal
she kept taking the classes
she spent two months
every monday night taking the hip-hop
improv beatbox rap classes
and just before
the world shut down in 2020 she gave a
concert performance with her class and
she had friends from all over see her
perform improv rap
she got so into it she even made a
youtube rap video which this screen
screenshot is taken from
but ultimately the question that i think
all of us can ask ourselves
as we think long term as we think about
our vision for our own lives and how we
want to lead them
is what kind of person do you want to be
what are you
optimizing for
with that
i'm going to
open it up for the conversation with
xander and i'm so glad to be here thank
you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
that was great all right um the
i said i'd love to start a little bit
with um you know your first couple books
were more specific kind of business
books and this is obviously a much
larger
picture thing how did you decide to do
this i think you decided to do this
before the the pandemic right and then
then the pandemic happened
i did i did
my first few business books were more
tactical in some ways my my first book
was about uh professional reinvention
i've written about how to become a
recognized expert in your field and a
book about
entrepreneurship and creating multiple
revenue streams in your business but as
i was thinking about the long game i
actually
in many ways hearkened back to
some of some of my early interests in my
early training
i was a philosophy major as an
undergraduate i have my master's degree
is in theology
and
i re it took me a long time to actually
piece together and to make this
connection sometimes people you know
they like to ask these sort of
super
insulting questions like you studied
philosophy do you ever use that
and i didn't have a good answer
but
what i came to realize
was in a lot of ways
our
in our contemporary american society
so much of our sense of personal meaning
derives from work
from you know the the work that we do or
who we are in the professional world i
realized that
philosophy and theology actually aren't
that far off from it that if we
really want to to meet people where
they're at and address their sense of
who they are in the world and what is
the impact they can make in the world
that bringing some of these
philosophical considerations to bear
is important and so i started looking
into that and diving into that
well
and i i think one of the things that you
brought up in the book that um
that i appreciated is that this idea
that we kind of obsess on on being busy
and you know you ask somebody how
they're doing and often the answer is
i'm so busy um but also that that is a
reflection on
um making us feel important and how that
one of the things you kind of have to
get over this
yeah it's it's really true there's been
some fascinating research uh notably by
sylvia bellezza at columbia university
that's talked about exactly this point
that in many cultures most notably
american culture dizziness really is a
form of status signaling that we are
essentially
finding a kind of politically correct
way of saying oh i'm so popular i'm so
in demand
i'm awesome
and
it's uh
we don't necessarily think of ourselves
as doing it but it's actually a little
bit obnoxious and we need to stop
right yeah i mean i think the
the true
the true power is being able to schedule
the downtime which i think you know you
talked about
and one of my favorite things is when
i'm going to do a trip or something and
then all of a sudden it gets canceled
and then i realize i have this openness
in my calendar
um but i think it's an interesting idea
of how to have you
thought about some of the techniques for
how how to do this in your life
yeah yeah absolutely when it comes to
actually you know sort of managing
calendars and carving things out
one of the the principles that has been
most helpful to me again to give a
little silicon valley shout out is a
concept that paul graham uh the founder
of y combinator has talked about um he's
written about manager schedule and maker
schedule and the way that it's sort of
played out in his essay was you think
about you know a manager at a tech
company and they're having meetings
they're supervising things they're
keeping the projects going uh
makers in in his world probably coders
are people who need large blocks of
unstructured time so they can dive in
and immerse themselves in projects
what i've actually found is that for
most professionals certainly this is
true for me
we actually kind of have to do both
right it can't be one or the other and
so i've modified this and in terms of my
own scheduling i have uh
for the past few years followed a
principle where i have what i call
maker days and manager days and so i
deliberately try to
pack all my meetings into one or two
days so that i'm just kind of going i'm
knocking them out and then frankly those
retiring days but what it enables what
it allows is for me to have the
completely unstructured maker days and i
use that for writing or for you know
so-called deep work
which is actually quite quite effective
to be able to do it it's it's really
hard to get into high quality work when
you only have a you know half an hour in
between meetings yeah so i mean we're
now stuck in an attention economy in
fact an economy that
sole goal is to distract us
um and every you know pretty much every
piece of code being written is how to
get you to be distracted um and i think
that's a it's an interesting question of
how
but nobody wants to be in that so it's
how are you thinking about how you get
out of the attention economy in that
space
yeah it it's true i mean we're
we're constantly being lured
i i think that
there are
individual questions about you know
what's what's the best thing for us i
mean i
um
i feel
like i have friends who have decided to
get off social media entirely and i
respect that that's great i mean i have
you know one good friend who who says
you know i have just found that i feel
happier not doing it that you know she
sort of monitored herself and she
realized she would get competitive or
she'd get depressed or whatever when
she'd see what other people were doing
and so she uh eliminated it entirely
i don't feel like that's necessary for
me
but
we have to
recognize the the parameters that we're
setting around
around these things and how we're using
them and
i think it's also useful to
understand what our goals are in things
um
i actually you know there's
there's so much backlash now i mean you
know for for years the tech world was
valorized probably to an excessive
extent um we're in a period now or the
tech world is being demonized i think to
an excessive extent but you know there
was a
oh this wonderful woman who helped raise
me she was our family housekeeper anne
and she died last year
but up until the end of her life i was
in you know good touch with anne and you
know called her regularly and things
like that
and you know anne died at 94
and every time i talk to her
she would tell me how much she loved
facebook
because
it was the only way that she was able to
keep
this ambient awareness of everyone in
her life
all her kids all her grandkids all her
great grandkids all the people around
her
they they often didn't remember to call
they didn't visit but she knew exactly
what was going on
and it was it was incredibly meaningful
to her and so i'm i'm never gonna
condemn
them universally they they help dan and
they help a lot of people so i think we
have to recognize
what is it good for and how does it work
in our lives right and it's
possibly why the next generation doesn't
seem to be getting on facebook because
their parents are on it but yeah
um
[Laughter]
you're mentioning of like how to
determine how to say no to things i
think is is one of the most uh
important skills that i'm certainly
trying to to learn and that you know
brian eno told me once he said anytime
somebody asked me to do something i
imagine that i have to do it tomorrow
and if i had to do it tomorrow would i
say yes and we have this thing where we
discount the future if it's six months
you're like oh fine i'll do it then but
with this principle of if i had to do it
tomorrow it like makes it very very
clear if you truly actually want to do
the thing um but i wonder if you could
say a little bit more about the the
principles on how to figure out how to
say no you you mentioned a few of them
but
if you could expand on that
yeah it is such an important question
one
framework that i think is is useful as
well this is this is like a low-hanging
fruit tip that i that i like to share
something that i
had to learn the hard way in my own
experience is that i often assumed
extremely erroneously that other people
had the same
uh had the same sort of framework or the
same view about what was urgent what was
worth somebody's time what was what was
worth a particular form of communication
what i've come to realize is you know
frankly there are some people out there
that just are exceedingly not busy they
have a lot of time on their hands and
they view things incredibly differently
and so
i would get requests sometimes and
people would say things like oh hey dory
uh are you you know are you free can can
you uh can you hop on a call
and
i
i would just assume like oh well if
somebody thinks that you know we need to
hop on a call right away it's got to be
a big thing
and
i came to realize like oh wait maybe
maybe not
not
so what i started doing is actually just
having an automatic request whenever
somebody is ambiguous because sometimes
they're ambiguous because they're busy i
get it sometimes they're ambiguous
because they forget
sometimes they're ambiguous because they
actually want to obfuscate their reasons
and so it's it's actually not uncommon
oh can we hop on a call because i want
to tell you about the new investment
that i want to pitch you can we hop on a
call because i i need your help with
this thing that i don't really want to
disclose up front and so even just
asking the question and getting clarity
okay i'd like to help you
what would you like to talk about
it's not it's not being aggressive it's
not you know sort of threatening
something but it is really helpful in
enabling you
to understand what you're in for what
you're being roped into so that you
actually can can dive in and just cut it
off and say oh you know thank you so
much xander i appreciate it but i'm
actually not investing in movies right
now or whatever it is i'm actually
curious for some more work on their part
yes yep
off offload the burden exactly i'm
actually curious i mean it's it's a
little bit of a heavy mantle to uh to be
running the long now foundation and to
in some ways be this like you know
paragon of
long-term thinking and yet have to run
an organization that has
so many day-to-day responsibilities like
any organization how do you thread that
needle how do you feel like you try to
live out the principles in terms of how
you conduct your work yeah i mean
obviously if you're trying to run a 10
000 organization you have to keep that
perspective but you also have to get
some things done um and so that um i
think it's it's a balance but i think
what's what's nice about having that
perspective is that
you have a slide appears that you don't
have to finish the work and so that i
think to that point it's to me it's like
how do i start the work in a way that
somebody else can finish it and that i
can hand it off at some point um but
it's it's actually very much on our mind
right now because we're just passing 25
years and we we are going to have to do
a generational shift so
one of the projects i've been working on
is researching how everybody else has
had long-term institutions so it's very
early in that research so i don't have
the answers yet but i hope to get a lot
of good stories from the longest lived
organizations in the world and be able
to come back and and talk about them at
some point so yeah it's uh it's very
much on my mind um
for sure and i think the
you mentioned like how you know when
when you have good ideas is not when
you're overworked
um and you know the certainly the best
ideas you know that i've ever had have
come in the interstitial times um but
you also have to load that with the
brain like with the parts of it that
um kind of inform you to it and so that
balance is something that i'm curious
about what you think about it's how do
you get enough kind of
the information in in but then have the
down time to to think about it
yeah it is it is an interesting balance
and an interesting challenge i remember
when i was in college and when i was in
graduate school
i actually
stopped reading for pleasure i'm not
sure if this was the case for for other
people as well but i had always been as
a kid a huge reader i loved reading
and
now you know as an adult i read all the
time
but when i was in school and was
essentially being forced uh to read
hundreds of pages of pretty dense text
every week uh when it became my job
it was no longer fun to do it
recreationally and something that had
been quite important to me kind of
atrophied in that way
and i think
that
for me one of the concepts that i was
mentioning in the talk about white space
i think part of why that's so resonant
is that what i've come to believe is
that for a lot of us you know for a lot
of you know
white-collar knowledge workers
the truth is
most of our jobs are actually pretty
cool most of it is actually pretty fun
not all of it of course i mean you know
you can't
it would be impossible to dream up a job
worth literally you loved every single
thing but for many of us we are in the
extremely fortunate position where most
of what we do is actually quite
interesting and quite
meaningful
but
there's a big but
it's that we
often
are forced to do so much of it in such a
compressed amount of time
that we actually
have a hard time enjoying any of it
even if on its own it would be fun it
would be interesting it would be good
it's really hard to enjoy something when
you're in a speed round or
you know when you
you know one scoop of ice cream is great
uh eating 25 scoops of ice cream is
gonna make you throw up
and so i think the question is how can
we just buy ourselves a little bit more
margin because just even a little bit
more space
in our lives to be able to slow down to
appreciate things to
be in the moment is what is going to
give us the ability to have that balance
to have the inputs but be able to think
about it and do something about it um
there's a folk band that i really like
called the niels and they have a song
lyric that i think applies
in many ways to our present predicament
um
they uh they say that the difference
between neurosis and psychosis is only
two hours of sleep
and i think with our jobs and with our
professional lives it's actually pretty
similar that you know
most of us have probably
tried to optimize and life hack our way
to a lot of things right i i am making
an educated guess here that most people
in this uh in this auditorium are not
actually the people who are spending 17
hours a week watching television right
it's not like oh just watch less
television you can get it all done like
no i get it that's not what you're doing
you are actually legitimately incredibly
busy
but
the battle
in many ways is one at the edges
this is about
reclaiming even an hour
two hours if we can manage but even an
hour a week
if we can weed whack our way through it
if we can fend off
excess commitments and frankly no one
else is going to do it for you you have
to be the vigilant gatekeeper here but
if you can buy yourself back an hour a
week
it gives you
space
to be able to enjoy things a little bit
more and to just think a little bit more
clearly to begin to get that space
that's necessary for long-term thinking
indeed um a couple questions from the
audience here elizabeth um
is asking what are you personally bad at
what have you decided to to be bad at um
and how has this worked in your strategy
oh it's such a good question uh so one
thing that i am super deliberately bad
at is i have never really learned to
cook properly and so i
live part-time in new york
and i buy all my food i just buy it out
and in miami i uh i pay someone to make
meals for me uh i i have just realized
it's not it's not worth the the time and
the learning some people actually really
relax in the kitchen i find it
incredibly stressful so i've given up on
that um also
i feel
i feel legitimately bad about this i'm
trying to give myself more grace but i
am uh sometimes bad at responding to
emails and so i have
you know messages that i have not
responded to that that you know sort of
haunt me but i try to just realize okay
you know they understand it's okay
you'll get to it uh and then you know i
i think bad at
might be the slight wrong uh wrong frame
so i'll put it in air quotes but i mean
the other uh you know honest truth is
that part of part of the way that i've
been able to spend a lot of time on my
career is i'm not married i don't have
kids these are trade-offs right and i
have
executive coaching clients and things
like that and they you know i mean
people beat themselves up about all
kinds of things but i have people who
you know oh they wish they could go to
this conference but it's the same
weekend as their daughter's lacrosse
meet and oh but there they might be all
the people that they could meet at the
conference and
that's all true that's all true uh it's
a choice
and i think that this is this is one of
the most powerful things um
francis fran morris say we have to
choose what to be bad at
it's not necessarily about being bad but
it means that we have to be willing to
make the choice and to understand all
right i may not be able to prioritize
this or to go all in on this at this
time because actually going to the
lacrosse meet is more important to me
and that is a very legitimate choice to
make but we need to be conscious about
about the choices we are making
nice yeah i chose to never match my
socks again i got all black socks
i don't know how much time that saves me
less cognitive load on my socks anyway
um and mariana senko um
is asking i think maybe how to expand
this thinking more in institutionally
given that the majority of our
institutions and companies exist on the
short timelines decades at best how how
could we incentivize them in a more
institutional environment and i and even
to that point one of the things i've
learned in my research about long-lived
companies is that the fortune 500
companies have in the 1950 were lasting
61 years and now they're less than 18
years old uh before so there's we're
losing almost one year per year of of
corporate longevity um in and of itself
so it's an interesting statistic for how
that's working
yes well i i am super eager for your
research standard because i feel like
you are going to answer this question in
a very definitive way
but i also i i think it's
it's hard honestly i mean a big part of
the reason
going back to one of the points in the
talk
a huge reason that amazon is able and
willing to make long-term choices is
well
the guy who started it
was running it
and
he was very comfortable with that
from the beginning i mean you know props
props where it's due
um
jeff bezos was willing to beat the drum
from the minute amazon went public don't
expect profits don't expect profits we
are reinvesting and that was that was
the terms um they were uh very
deliberate about reattaching
that letter that original shareholder
letter to every subsequent shareholder
letter as a reminder for anyone who
might erroneously think that profits
would be coming i mean now of course
profits are rolling in but it took a
really long time because they were
willing to defer a deferred fur and
invest
and
i actually think that that structurally
it is
extremely hard because if you do not
have
the owner uh who is uh running it you
have a lot of people who
in our current climate i mean i know
people at the long now foundation are in
it for the long term you have been here
from the beginning i know danielle's
been here for 16 years i mean the
longevity is amazing because of um
because of the the commitment the
commitment to the vision and that sort
of shared understanding but in most
corporate jobs i mean we know this if
somebody stays you know 25 years 16
years at a corporate job we're like what
you know it's like oh my god they're
from the 50s uh it's incredibly rare and
as a result of that
people are making choices that are
optimized for themselves rather than for
the entity and so if you have a super
mission-driven organization where
everyone is bought into that shared
vision which you know that that's a
powerful thing for a company to create
then we might be able to overcome the
natural bias of self-interest but
without that it's it's really hard to do
indeed yeah one of the other things i
remember jeff telling me is that the
when that stock prices were doubling
he made sure to tell every all the
employees that you are not twice as
smart as you were last quarter
and when it goes down by half you're not
gonna be twice as dumb so just like
don't pay an attention to that and i
think that was probably very because a
lot of those companies when the stock
prices went down they just all the
employees just left because they felt
they were failing um so it's an
interesting one back to your failure
points um adam is asking um
what is some long-term thinking or
strategic advice that you think is
dangerous or disagree with
that's great
dangerous long-term thinking well i i
think that it
an example of of you know
dangerous long-term thinking
would be
this
in general
we know human nature is
optimized for the short term right i
mean for any of us just rationally if
you can have a good thing now or if you
can have a good thing in 20 years well
sure let's take the good thing now
that's that's sort of how we are we have
to consciously override it
to
become
sufficient long-term thinkers and for
some things you need to because for
certain meaningful hard worthy goals
you're only going to get there the only
path to it is long-term thinking
in general that is a good thing it is
worth aspiring to where it becomes
dangerous is the following
and my friend marshall goldsmith the
well-known executive coach he has a book
coming out about this actually um in a
month or two called the earned life and
i think it's a really important point um
he says that something that we often
fail to to do you know we get so good
at saving for the rainy day we get so
good at deferring gratification
some of us actually err on the side
of never properly celebrating our
accomplishments we err on the side of uh
you know
saving all the money never never
spending it never enjoying it never
taking advantage of
the things that we've earned
and i think this is a situation where we
need to have you know moderation in all
things um
it's not really much
fun for anyone i don't i don't think it
you could call it a real success
for somebody to
die at the end of their lives um just
having kept their head down and had this
onerous
grueling existence because they keep
putting it off for another day another
day another day and they never actually
get to enjoy the fruits of what they've
done that doesn't mean you blow it it
doesn't mean that you are
celebrating excessively or you're not
putting aside money for charity or for
relatives or things like that but i
think it's
this kind of
abstemiousness can become a
self-perpetuating cycle and it's
important to celebrate the victories and
it's important to enjoy our lives along
the way
yeah now if you've ever sat with
somebody who's passed passing away they
never sit there and say i wish i worked
harder
they usually say i wish i took that
vacation
so yeah um i said we're gonna we're
gonna wrap this up um but kevin kelly is
gonna get the the last question
um
what is your 10-year project that you
are working on
so my 10-year project i alluded to this
a little bit uh during during the talk
but in 2016
i decided that i was going to learn to
write musical theater and it actually
came out of a very specific circumstance
in 2015 the year before
i
went a little crazy with work i guess
you could say i was launching a book and
i
and the honest truth was
i was
feeling a little
depressed and so
as a way of
burying that
i went on the road
and so i gave 74 talks that year
which was a lot
uh it came out to about one and a half
talks every week
and so that meant i was pretty much on a
plane
once or twice every week and i was so
incredibly exhausted at the end of the
year i was i was sick i was just run
down and i thought you know why why am i
doing this why am i why did i decide it
was a good idea to run myself to the
point of exhaustion
and i was living in new york at the time
and i realized
why am i paying so much money to live in
new york when i'm not actually in new
york i'm just on planes it seemed really
ridiculous and so i came up with a new
year's resolution for myself and my new
year's resolution
was that as a way of
leaning into the city as a way of kind
of reconnecting and appreciating where i
was
i was going to do one uniquely new york
activity per week
something that you could only do in new
york so you know maybe it's see a
broadway show or go to a museum or you
know take a
you know dumpling tour of chinatown or
you know whatever it is
so one of the first things that i did
was a guy that i knew invited me to a
broadway show and so i said yes i will
go to that show with you it was like my
first week's activity
and i went to this show i went to see
fun home which won the 2016 yes won the
2016 tony award a really amazing show
and the truth was i lived in new york
about a year and a half by that point i
had only been to one broadway show i
really hadn't taken advantage of that
but i saw this show and it just hit me
and i
went home and i woke up the next morning
and i was seized with this feeling with
this this this sense that i needed to
learn to write musical theater
and i decided to pursue that and
i have done so since then and so i i've
taken you know trainings and fellowships
and and moved it forward but what i've
come to learn is that the average show
that it's it's a long process it takes
about seven years on average seven or
eight years for a show to go from
inception to actually making it to
broadway there's a lot of steps along
the way so in 2016 i decided that i
would create a 10-year goal for myself
to have a
show on broadway for the 2026 season so
we're in 2022 so i'm working on it
thank you so much
you
[Music]
you